game 1 surprised go Master Yi Sado game
2 left him speechless and in game 3 he
felt powerless so dole came back to win
and game 4 but the final game ended with
google's alphago defeating the go master
again a computer had beaten the best go
player in the world 4 to 1 the weight of
this defeat stirred a certain sadness
and many people around the world because
unlike chess go is a complex game that
requires human intuition and creativity
or so it was thought alphago system uses
deep neural networks which approximate
the web of neurons in the human brain
these networks learn to perform tasks by
analyzing large amounts of digital data
the alphago team took it a step farther
using reinforcement learning they set up
countless matches in which different
versions of alphago played each other so
alphago learns from human moves and then
it develops its own strategy it
understands how humans play but it can
also look beyond that to play an
entirely different level of the game
this may seem frightening but the
reality is but the technologies at the
heart of alphago are the future they're
poised to reinvent everything from
robotics to scientific research in the
years to come as we humans work with
these machines our genius will only grow
in tandem with our creations well
hopefully so don't view it as human
versus machine but rather human and
machine